بغض النظر عن الطريقة التي تنظر بها ، لا يوجد
طريق سهل للاستئناف ، وأساسًا لدى
البريطانيين ، فإن الخيار الأول في
الوقت الحالي هو أن يتولى وستمنستر زمام
الأمور الآن ، فنحن نشهد هذا الأمر
أكثر فأكثر حيث يضيف البرلمان تعديلات جديدة
ترفض قبول الصفقة التي تطلبها
تساءل ما هو الخيار
الذي سيقبلونه والذي يقودنا إلى
مسألة استئناف المفاوضات في
نطاق الاتحاد الأوروبي الآن أوضح الاتحاد
الأوروبي بالفعل أنهم لن
يعيدوا فتح الصفقة التي تم وضعها في
موضع اتفاق الانسحاب
والإعلان السياسي  إذا ظل
هذا هو الحال إذا لم يقدم أي من
الجانبين أرضًا جيدًا ، فحينئذٍ تنتقل إلى
الخيار الثالث ، وهو إمكانية إجراء
انتخابات عامة في المملكة المتحدة
بعد تصويت بحجب الثقة وتصويت الشعب في
الاستفتاء الثاني التالي ،
ولكنك  أريد أن أضع ذلك لأنه إذا
لم يحدث أي من هذه الأمور ، فأنت
قريب بشكل خطير من الخيار الرابع
الذي لا يعد حقًا خيارًا على الإطلاق
للخروج من الاتحاد الأوروبي.  قال دى إن
الجميع يقولون إنهم لا يريدون
الانهيار ولكن مع استمرار الأمور في الوقت
الحالي ، ينفد الطريق في 29 مارس
وهناك انخفاض حاد في النهاية
لا يمكن للمشرعين الاتفاق على مسار بالفعل
ما إذا كانوا يريدون ذلك  بريجز على الإطلاق